[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
welt heute gibt ein leckeres
weihnachtsmenü und zwar premiere auf
meinem kanal ich werde heute ende zu
bereiten also enden forst und dazu
gibt's zwei winter salate und zwar ein
weißkohl salat und einen blinden salat
mit tomaten auf feldsalat richtig lecker
die geschichte zudem sind gerichtes
folgendermaßen ich bin früher freunde
kennengelernt habe habe ich wirklich
ganz folgen und chinesen essen kann man
immer richtig lecker nur das problem ist
an chinesen das im untermarkt heimat ist
kannst du dich noch welche nichts mehr
machen ja aber dann habe ich einen
chinesen brot der sozusagen zwischen war
jemand wofür verwendet dessen und
seitdem ich sicher die flasche gehabt
zum nachwürzen
seitdem zentren ist alles weg und auf
jeden fall jetzt wohl meine ich muss mir
schmeckt wirklich wahnsinn und ich habe
heute ein paar tipps und tricks für euch
wie die ente auch gelingt denn viele
trauen sich da gar nicht dran aber wir
werden jetzt zuerst einmal für den
zeitlichen ablauf die salate zubereiten
und dafür zeige ich euch jetzt mal die
zutaten für den weiß konstant brauche
ich 300 gramm weißkohl einen apfel eine
karotte eine rote paprika einen halben
teelöffel salz einen viertel teelöffel
kreuzkümmel hier habe ich 30 milliliter
öl also sammlung um 25 millimeter
apfelessig zwei teelöffel honig und auch
etwas pfeffer nämlich zuerst einmal den
weißkohl der schon ziemlich groß und da
brauche ich jetzt wie gesagt 300 gramm
davon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diesen strukturen den nämlich raus das
äußere blatt habe ich jetzt weggenommen
und wehrt den weißkohl jetzt erst mal
fein hobeln
das könnte jetzt mit einer küchenrolle
machen oder auch mit der küchenmaschine
das geht ein bisschen einfacher
den kann jetzt schon mal umfüllen mit
einem messer könntet ihr natürlich auch
ganz fein schneiden
und ich werde jetzt hier oben auch
gleich die karotte rasten dann hab ich
auch schon mal erledigt
[Applaus]
zum beispiel gebe ich jetzt noch einen
halben teelöffel salz - denn jetzt erst
mal weich kneten und zwar deswegen ja
damit einfach weiß wird und das mache
ich jetzt mit einem handschuh weil ich
einfach das salz auf meiner haut ist
haben da bin ich mal wieder empfindlich
und das könnte jetzt schön ein paar
minuten durchkneten
[Musik]
es kann als kurz zur seite jetzt kann
ich den april nehmen vierteln und in
kernen und auch die paprika entkernen
und setzte dann in feine würfel
schneiden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in einem kleinen topf erwärmen kurzes
dressing
so löst sich erst mal der honig gut in
der flüssigkeit auf und außerdem kann es
dann wirklich besser sich mit dem
weißkohl verbinden
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich im prinzip alles
miteinander verbinden
das heißt alles rein zum weißkohl
[Musik]
das war mit dressing dann auch ein
bisschen kreuzkümmel da können dann nach
geschmack mit dazu geben also wenn ihr
den geschmack nicht zusammen dann geht
nicht alles mit rein und ein bisschen
pfeffer und dann wird das ganze noch mal
durch gerührt
den salat stecke ich jetzt ablassen
anderer seite steht und zeigt euch schon
mal die zutaten für den leckeren
linsensalat hätten linsensalat braucht
ihr 100 gramm rote linsen 50 gramm fett
salat
ich habe ich fünf esslöffel olivenöl 2
es noch weiß wenn es sich einen halben
teelöffel zucker 2 tomaten der rote
zwiebel etwas petersilie salz und
pfeffer zuerst nimmt jetzt die roten
linsen die habe ich jetzt bereits unter
kaltem wasser abgespült bis die
flüssigkeit einfach klar herausgekommen
ist die commons in einem topf und da
gebe ich jetzt genügend wasser dazu so
dass sie gut bedeckt sind
und lasst sie ist hier erst einmal
aufkochen und dann bei mittlerer stufe
etwa 10 bis 15 minuten gar kochen bis
sie fast durch sind in der zeit stelle
ich die zutaten für den salat mal zur
seite und zeigt euch jetzt mal die
entenbrust ich habe jetzt zwei
entenbrüste und zwar solltet ihr da beim
kauf darauf achten dass sie von einer
weiblichen entstammen
denn die sind etwas kleiner und zarter
in der textur und die sind leider auch
recht wunderschön ich habe sie auch
schon abgetupft mit einem küchenpapier
jetzt muss ich die haut einschneiden
einfach damit sie sich beim braten nicht
zusammen sieht und damit raus kommt und
da müssen jetzt ganz darauf achten dass
er nur die haut einschneidet und nicht
das fleisch und daneben auch so fein wie
möglich also etwa 1 cm breit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt nämlich noch mal handschuhe
denn jetzt kommt die gewürzmischung
drauf ich habe jetzt hier eine
gewürzmischung da habe ich ein bisschen
lavendel drin basilikum oregano thymian
knoblauch salz ein bisschen zucker aber
die genaue menge schreibe ich euch
natürlich auf den block riecht auch
richtig toll und ich nehme ich
handschuhe weil ich ansonsten den ganzen
geschmack jetzt an den händen habe das
mariechen richtig gut bin ich noch drin
und knoblauch und es muss jetzt schön
einmassiert werden und das kann es ja
was ganz neues bonus nur für die info
oder allgemein geflügel gar keine
allgemeine meinung zu ende passt halt
gut
ich sage immer ente gut alles gut
jedes mal meinen spruch ja oder ganz
oder gar nicht
schön einmal sehen also ganz ehrlich als
in acht jahren ehe hast mich noch nie so
maximilian wusst ich schaue keine ändern
[Musik]
jetzt sieht man ganz gut dass die ente
anfängt zu glänzen und zwar kommt jetzt
das eigene fed der ente raus und dadurch
gelangen die gewürze in die ente rein
und somit den geschmack richtig schön
mit dabei
[Musik]
genug passiert jetzt dazu bereitet ganz
wichtig ist bei der ente dass sie in die
kalte pfanne gelegt wird da gibt es auch
verschiedene zubereitungs techniken und
ich zeige euch jetzt die technik im
backofen
ich lege jetzt die ente so ein bisschen
kompakt dass ich hab so ein bisschen
zusammengeschoben ihnen meine kalte
pfanne
ich nehme es hier eine eisen pfanne denn
die darf auch in den backofen das heißt
falls jetzt keine pfanne hat einen
backofen darf könnt ihr zum beispiel
auch ein bus alten vornehmen oder auch
irgendein anderes geschirr was eben da
habt ein backblech zum beispiel dadurch
dass die ente jetzt in die kalte pfanne
gelegt wurde wird sie jetzt im ofen nur
langsam warm
ich mache das jetzt so ich habe den ofen
bereits auf 180 grad ober unterhitze
vorgeheizt ihr könnt sehr woche den
kalten backofen schieben aber da geht es
ganz ein bisschen länger jetzt passiert
folgendes die entenbrust wird ganz
langsam warm dass heißes fett fett wird
warm und tritt langsam aus dadurch wird
die haut unten gebräunt und
karamellisiert auch und später wenn es
anfängt zu purzeln also da müsste auch
ihr gehör achten das dauert jetzt bei
mir etwa fünf bis zehn minuten weil der
ofen schon vorgeheizt ist müsse darauf
hören wenn es anfängt zu brutzeln werde
ich dann die entenbrust drehen und dann
zeige ich euch die weiteren
vorbereitenden schritte
[Musik]
die linsen sind mittlerweile auch hier
schützt die flüssigkeit weg aber falls
jetzt noch flüssigkeit drin sein sollte
dass sie abgießen und die sind jetzt
noch ein bisschen bissfest und die sind
so perfekt für den salat
die lasse ich jetzt ein bisschen
abkühlen und kann jetzt hier schon mal
die tomaten halbieren und da nehme ich
jetzt die kerne raus und werde die aber
fürs dressing weiterverwenden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und ich glaube die ente ruft uns kippte
man fertig schauen
es riecht auch schon richtig gut 80
griff es sieht auch das ganze eigene fed
von der ente ich habe kein zusätzliches
fett mit dazu gegeben
gleichzeitig sie wenden
und so dass sie noch mal zwei drei
minuten weiter garen am ende werde ich
sie noch mal wenden damit sie schön groß
wird als nächstes werde ich jetzt noch
die petersilie und die zwiebel fein
hacken
die kommen dann mit zu den tomaten
[Musik]
zu den tomaten kennen gebe ich jetzt das
olivenöl dazu weiß man endlich dem
zucker da hebt den geschmack und
bisschen salz und pfeffer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kommt das dressing über dem salat
gemeinsam mit den noch warmen linsen
[Musik]
alles gut durchmischen und dann gerne
nochmal abschmecken mit salz und pfeffer
so wird sich auch die österreich jetzt
richtig noch einmal um auf die hautseite
damit die hautseite schön kross wird
unterstrichen könnte richtig lecker ist
dass ich die so noch mal eine minute im
backofen und dann werde ich den backofen
ausschalten und die ente 23 minuten lang
ziehen lassen und in der zeit kennen
wohl die salate an recht nur sauber
machen so lieber murat ist die ente
also ich finde es hier sieht wunderschön
aus hat mich nie getraut also dass die
selber zu machen und vor allem trauen
sich auf wieder zuschauen kannte ich
muss sagen ich mochte enter eigentlich
nie hat mich der murat so ein bisschen
dazu gebracht
aber ich war ungefähr acht jahren bei
chinese ist so kann ja sagen ja wenn du
mich wirklich nicht mehr hinauf naja wie
jeden tag in gang zum chinesen
interessen aber seid ihr mit sell
außerdem sally da ist hat es mein büro
also jetzt kann ich die ente
aufschneiden und zwar von oben herunter
als jetzt die hautseite oben ein
bisschen der wo nach unten damit noch
richtig glücklich jetzt
und es ist so richtig wissen frische
ende ist also kein gefrorene richtig
schöne falsche ende
wann ich will jetzt die salate zerstört
halt dem du eigentlich nicht so gerne
hören möchte
aber es passt halt perfekte zusätzliches
salat wie salsa dieses alles weg
wiesenhof hat in fenstern auf der
anderen seite den weißkohl salat
weißkohl schöne winter salat liebe weiß
privates ente gut alles gut
das ist wirklich wirklich probieren
sagte mir schon manchmal abweisen und
dann müssen uns fotografieren und dann
müssen es schadet die aber nicht wenn du
nicht alles auf einmal ob ich jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt
hinter ist vom geflügel her als ich habe
früher hat nur hähnchen und butter
gegessen und es ist so einen
geschmacklichen ganz untypisches
geflügel finde ich die idee ist
natürlich gut kann es weiterempfehlen
aufgeben
vor allem dieses gewürz also mir ist
völlig daheim nach macht macht auch
dieses gewürz nach geht schon die
teilnahme an den hintern wenn du wenn du
ganz lieb zu mir bestand bereitet 88
dann bereitet dass das wir gerne noch
einmal so bitte ich bin ja und falls ihr
jetzt auch dieses rezept nach machen
wollt dann geht auch sally blog.de da
stets unter der kategorie morath
lieblingsgerichte und dann steht nur
dieses einzige gericht wahrscheinlich
drin
es steht unter hauptgerichte und dann
wünsche ich euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen vielleicht das ist eine idee
für euer weihnachtsmenü ich denke es ist
etwas sehr besonderes und was richtig
richtig leckeres und wünsche euch dabei
ganz viel spaß
bis zum nächsten mal genau traut euch
ruhig ein paar tipps sich jetzt euch
gegeben hat sind wirklich echt klasse
format möglich klasse becker stop shop
ich hab noch gar nicht lange her sagt
der schmidt gigantisch wirklich also was
ich es lese ja eher links salat einfach
genial wirklich glänzen verlangen und
weißkohl salat ganz gut und schmeckt
alles gut möglich
also lasse keine salate der salat
schmeckt auch super session
das freut mich also viel spaß machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]